historiquement le cyclisme est vraiment un
sport européen si vous étiez le patron vous
étiez le patron et cette personne a établi la
culture il n'y avait pas d'autre équipe
autour de vous et permettant à quelqu'un
avec une personnalité différente vous aviez un
américain greg lamont qui était un
monde junior  le champion a fait irruption sous la scène en tant que
star et il se faufilait hors de l'
hôtel après avoir brûlé 8 000 calories
pendant la journée
pour avoir un peu de glace mais s'il se
faisait prendre, il avait des ennuis avec
certaines équipes, vous les regarderiez et ça
semble vraiment robotique de l'extérieur,
le système était vraiment bloqué
[Musique]
sauf que [
Musique]
est [
moi-même
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
oui [
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien, où l'équipe verte a-t-elle commencé
garçon c'était une idée originale de jerry ryan
il n'y avait aucun doute sur le fait que j'ai grandi
à bendigo qui est une
ville cyclable j'avais un vélo mais
beaucoup d'ambitions mais très peu de
capacités et jerry a un
passé ouvrier et vous regardez
un  beaucoup de sports qu'il soutient ou
les clubs qu'il soutient sont des
cyclistes de la classe ouvrière pour les raisons des
qualités des athlètes viennent de
l'avoir
donc le travail acharné la ténacité la
résilience
qu'il admirait
un petit détour un moment
ça a été une journée spéciale  et john tu as
déclaré que tu as déclaré que quelque chose
irait mal sans
hébergement alors je suis assis là à
regarder toutes les équipes arriver
à paris pour la dernière fois
et
chaque voiture avait un drapeau de pays dessus
il n'y avait pas de drapeau australien
alors j'ai sonné  Shane Bannon et et je
conduisais ce fan
vers Brasha en pensant qu'est-ce qu'il
veut parler de ce qu'il
faut pour
mettre en place une équipe parce que l'année prochaine
je veux voir un drapeau australien
sur une voiture je ne savais pas quoi  dire que je
savais que c'était l'
opportunité pour laquelle
beaucoup d'entre nous travaillaient depuis
environ 20 ans,
Shane Bannon a joué un rôle
déterminant dans la croissance du
cyclisme australien et il a été impliqué dans la
carrière de nombreux cyclistes australiens
qui ont réussi à  le sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire alors
pourquoi ne soutiendriez-vous pas qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour planifier
nous nous sommes lancés
dans le voyage sans sponsor majeur
[Musique]
il y a 18 équipes dans la première division du
cyclisme mondial et
star de cinéma sky bmc ils '  re les meilleurs
et oraca se trouve quelque part au
milieu et c'est un peu comme ce film ou
la boule d'argent du livre il s'agit d'utiliser le
budget à bon escient le plus d'argent ne
donne pas nécessairement les meilleurs résultats les
directeurs sportifs d'une équipe
sont les plus  des gens importants maintenant, je veux dire que
ces gars sont des
colonels du plan de bataille,
ils ont leur armée et ils vont
planifier tous les jours et Matt White a
apporté du plaisir dans l'équipe mais sérieux, il
peut laisser tomber ses cheveux, il sait comment
amusez-vous après la tombée de la nuit
[Musique]
humain,
il est de chair et de sang bon dans certaines choses
et probablement
pas bon dans d'autres comme parfaitement
imparfait si vous voyez ce que je veux dire,
d'habitude, nous ne nous arrêtons pas à McDonald's mais
euh c'est plus calme et nous sommes assez limités
à  nos trucs et comme vous pouvez le voir les garçons
profitent de leur nourriture nutritive
[Applaudissements]
neil est assez euh
brusque ce n'est pas le bon mot
mais il l'est certainement c'est très noir sur
blanc qu'est-ce que tu crois que tu
fais
[Applaudissements]
et il court  en eux
il a établi le premier contact
j'ai laissé tomber la bombe f un peu
parfois un peu passionné par
la façon dont je m'exprime non ne chante pas
continue ça va allez tu
peux le faire un peu plus
[ __ ] allons-y allons [ __ ] allons allons [ __ ]
oui oh
[ __ ]
je sais que
tu sais que tu as été têtu je suppose que comme nous le
sommes tous alors je sais que c'est la
bonne façon de le faire il dit que c'est
la bonne façon de le faire shane  pourrait dire
que c'est la bonne façon de le faire nous avons eu nos
conflits vous savez nous euh nous avons verrouillé la
sélection des coureurs de cornes je dirais que ce
serait le point qui a été le plus
discuté nous voulons créer une
équipe internationale avec l'adn australien
nous avions deux  des
niveaux de coureurs très distincts, nous avions le
groupe de jeunes talentueux dont nous aurons
besoin de quelques années pour vraiment
mûrir, puis nous voulions entourer
ces gars avec les gars de l'expérience uber
qui avaient été là comme stuart
o'grady robbie  mcewen baden cook
étaient tous des coureurs emblématiques à leur
époque particulière lorsque vous avez commencé à créer
une équipe, vous avez besoin d'écrivains qui peuvent
obtenir des résultats,
mais probablement plus important encore, vous avez besoin
d'écrivains qui définissent la culture et c'est
pourquoi simon garens était la signature clé
lorsque cette équipe  je me suis établi
je n'ai jamais vraiment rêvé dès mon plus jeune âge de
concourir en tant que professionnel,
cela semblait tellement exagéré parce que j'étais
asthmatique et mes parents et mon entraîneur
m'ont encouragé à faire un peu de natation
alors j'étais dans le club de natation et
en compétition aussi, donc peu
importait vraiment ce que je faisais,
je voulais y participer quand
l'institut australien du
sport lui a dit qu'en tant que moins de 23 ans, vous n'êtes probablement pas
assez bon pour trouver un autre travail, il
est allé courir  en norvège avec une petite
équipe et à peine joint les deux bouts qui
n'a pas tout à fait fonctionné à 24 25
ans il courait en tant qu'amateur en
france
et il était le meilleur amateur de france
cette année-là a obtenu son premier
contrat professionnel puis a gardé  il suffit de
grignoter et d'apporter ces améliorations
guerrero
il me fait peur parfois
il est très exigeant sur la mécanique
il est très exigeant sur les réalisateurs
il est très exigeant sur le personnel mais si
vous creusez un peu plus profondément vous
le regardez et la personne la plus exigeante est
sur  lui-même
parfois je pense
comment avez-vous l'énergie pour cela, comment
pouvez-vous être dérangé pour cela, mais c'est
une grande qualité qui m'enflamme aussi alors
je me sens assez chanceux
d'avoir son énergie
autour de nous
au cours de notre première année d'emploi ou
de contrat  30 coureurs maintenant, c'est la capacité de l'équipe à assurer
le service et à maximiser le
service entourant ces coureurs, nous avons
deux bus deux camions
six fans 14 voitures trois médecins physios
10 missours 10 mécaniciens
deux entraîneurs
un physiologiste du sport
où nous voyons l'équipe aller est à la
fin du  jour juste parce que vous avez
un passeport australien ne signifie pas que
vous avez un emploi à vie ici, vous savez que c'est
cette équipe numéro un qui concerne
la performance s'il n'est pas la bonne personne ou
s'il n'est pas le bon talent que nous étions
nous regardions autour du marché et obtenions
d'autres personnes de différents
pays
swain touffes son nom de famille le résume il est
l'ours grylls du cyclisme il survivra
quelles que soient les circonstances vous
savez que j'avais l'habitude d'empiler des traverses de chemin de fer la
construction a travaillé dans euh nettoyer un
boucherie et je ne connaissais rien à
la course de vélo à l'époque, mais je savais juste que
j'aimais me pousser et j'ai acheté un
vélo d'occasion et j'ai construit une remorque
et
j'ai jeté tout mon équipement là-dedans et mon
chien aussi et et j'ai juste commencé à faire
des expéditions  jusqu'au nord de la
colombie britannique, j'étais vraiment libre de beaucoup de
ces choses matérielles qui
vous maintiennent en quelque sorte lié
au monde et à la société en ce moment
avec des fans et créer une chaîne youtube
et j'espère que si nous faisions du contenu que non
seulement vos fans de cyclisme inconditionnels pourraient
regarder, nous pourrions créer un peu de
base d'abonnés,
donc quand nous avons commencé, nous avons essentiellement filmé
des vidéos de cuisine et vous savez
des vidéos de pêche et nous avions  un cheval de course qui
n'a rien fait de bien euh mais nous voulions juste
vraiment extraire les personnalités de
ces gars
il euh il sort le bogan et
tout le monde à un art donc euh
tu ne peux pas t'aider de temps en
temps  vous dites des trucs idiots, regardez, il
y avait un peu de peur avec tous ces
Australiens qui se réunissaient que ça
allait être une grande une grande équipe de fête grande
euh
un gros gros groupe de gars vous savez tous dans
la même équipe finalement euh ayant  un bon
moment euh et c'était définitivement un peu
ça au début
[Applaudissements]
de l'extérieur ça ressemblait à une équipe
qui s'amusait
mais étaient-ils sérieux
[Rires]
[Musique]
à cause du fait qu'on a passé tout
ça  années dans les équipes européennes maintenant nous avions
notre propre équipe et notre propre culture mais
quand j'ai regardé en arrière, je ne
pense pas que nous savions vraiment ce que nous faisions
ouais alors nous faisons
des exercices de sprint et euh c'est autour  environ un
effort de trois kilomètres, nous devrions en quelque sorte
rouler pendant quelques k, puis pour une
cage, juste peler ouais jens morris
mène le coucou de jen clair ernest
doit rester avec thomas un grand
groupe vous faites la course l'un contre l'autre nous avons jamais
eu  une trousse de premiers soins dans la voiture
et et nous avons des serpents pour le gagnant
nous avons des serpents pour les gagnants j'ai fait
nous avons dû contourner les gars et faire
la ligne d'arrivée la ligne d'arrivée
allait être là où se trouve la voiture
[Musique]
alors nous avons garé la voiture et je suis arrivé un
peu chaud
sur l'herbe là-bas et aussi je n'avais pas
réalisé que la route s'éloignait
si fortement ouais nous sommes foutus si c'est le cas
[Musique]
oh merde
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as compris,
sortons la voiture puis conduisons-
le à l'hôpital
euh je me suis
fracturé l'omoplate tu sais que j'ai eu
pas mal d'accidents au cours de ma vie mais je n'en ai
jamais eu
à l'entraînement alors tu le sais  a été un peu
un choc pour moi et qu'est-ce que nous nous exposons
à ce risque car ce n'était probablement pas la
chose idéale à faire à cette période de
l'année
hors ligne que faites-vous je vais aller
à l'hôpital avec les garçons
le plus gros problème pour une équipe comme celle-ci le
plus grand défi auquel ils sont confrontés est que faites-
vous et il y a
un peu de bêtise ou il y a une petite
erreur ou vous mettez tous vos œufs dans
le même panier et vous  n'arrive pas
avec le vent beaucoup d'équipes se désagrègent
parce que la camaraderie n'est pas bonne et
dès qu'il y a une déception tout le
monde commence à s'en
vouloir oh c'est de sa faute oh c'est de sa
faute oh il ne faut pas assigner ce coureur
oh  c'est un sponsor de merde nous sommes
toujours à ballarat avec des boîtes de roues
et d'engrenages et des trucs qui ont été
expédiés du japon et les cadres avaient
été expédiés de suisse il y avait
leurs vêtements n'étaient pas tout à fait corrects euh
il y avait un peu de  cette confusion
parce que nous n'avons pas eu le temps de
trop réfléchir à la tactique ou aux
conditions de vent ou à ce genre de choses, nous
essayions juste de mettre les vélos sur la route
et oui, il y avait une
grande anticipation sur la façon dont ils
vont aller
le  la saison cycliste s'est interrompue aux
trois grands grands tours les courses de trois semaines
tours de france italie et espagne
et les cinq monuments les grandes courses d'un jour
dont quatre sont au début de
la saison les classiques du printemps milan san
remo a été le premier grand  course de la
saison l'une des plus importantes c'était
leur premier grand objectif et ce serait
le premier vrai test ont-ils fait
assez de travail pour se préparer
les européens sont venus en australie
ils savent que les australiens sont des gens durs
mais c'est là que ça se termine
ils  sais quand ils entrent dans leur
jardin en europe c'est là que vivent les vrais
cyclistes
[musique]
le milan san remo est la plus longue
classique d'un jour au monde
l'une des plus belles courses du
calendrier les italiens vous diront que c'est
la plus  belle
[Musique]
ce classique reçoit une énorme publicité
dans le monde parce qu'il commence l'
année en ce qui les concerne
depuis milan, c'est à 300 kilomètres jusqu'à
la côte et tous ces grands champions qui le
gagnent ne font qu'ajouter à l'histoire ajoute
à la mystique de  la course
[Musique]
quiconque gagne milan san remo est une
rock star instantanée en italie ce
sont les garçons dans le bus
bon esprit
seulement 300k pour vous faire vous-même vous êtes plus
précieux que le dernier homme
tout le monde ressent les effets
oh cher oh shill  porte sur le sol
ouais mon pote
est-ce cinq ou six sous terre je
ne vois aucun des nôtres d'accord non non nous sommes
prêts à partir nous sommes prêts à partir
neuf kilomètres pour aller maintenant au euh
poggio que j'ai  j'ai l'impression que fabian
regarde de cette façon il a l'air si
calme
papi cancillaro il l'a appelé spartacus
spartacus a tout parlé avec sa
lance et son bouclier c'est une énorme victoire pour
fabian catcher d'autres coureurs ont regardé
cancellar et ils étaient ils avaient
peur parce qu'ils  craignaient que s'ils
le laissaient partir d'une longueur, ils n'allaient pas
le récupérer et gary tu sais
quoi faire sur la pièce de théâtre joe
[Musique]
alors que johnny hoogalan passe et
passe tout droit devant vincenzo grignote avec
simon guerins dans son  gagner
juste à côté de garen
et annulaire devant répondre
et c'est parti
c'est la descente à la fois de grignotage et d'
annulation peut descendre comme une pierre
c'est comme ça que garrett prend juste le
volant prend le volant
et sur cette dernière descente du poggio
qu'il faisait  1 000 watts à chaque
virage en sprintant pour rester avec fabian l'un
des meilleurs descendeurs au monde que
je les ai fait tomber en essayant de
les faire tomber peut-être cinq mètres sur simon oh
ça pourrait être dangereux il a juste la
tête baissée et il essaie  pleuvoir aussi
fort que possible
eh bien j'étais comme
juste
crier à la télévision dans la
descente pour remonter sur cette roue oh
il revient
allez tu ne peux pas lui donner un mètre
il n'y a pas assez d'espace pour qu'ils commencent à
jouer au chat et à la souris  giro parfait il suffit de
prendre le volant
[Musique]
12 secondes ils ont cancellara a la
tête baissée le quadruple champion du monde du contre-
la-montre sous le
kilomètre à parcourir banner
boys croise les doigts
regarde par-dessus son épaule fabian casual
pas la position qu'il aurait  j'aime être dedans
mais il sera toujours un homme marqué
pour ce genre de chose
le
côté gauche il va gagner charlie le
prend simon
prend un monument
Je ne
respire
pas tout à fait mais comme si je m'en fichais,
je ne crois pas que ce jerry ment si
chanceux qu'il
va gagner le plus grand
classique du monde du premier
coup, cela a montré que c'était
une
vraie équipe une équipe sérieuse ouais je  Je ne
pense pas que celui-ci va s'enfoncer pendant un
petit moment,
alors j'ai téléchargé toutes les séquences vidéo sur
YouTube et je n'y ai pas vraiment pensé,
mais ce n'est que lorsque nous sommes allés en
Amérique peu de temps après que j'ai pensé
à vous  sais que ces vidéos commencent
à voyager
nous sommes à la télé les gars oh je suis backstreet's
pass
quoi de neuf
oh c'est tellement cool je
vais dire quelques mots à australia
angel city mon groupe préféré les anges
m'emmènent pour
avoir un singe sur le dos  ah
je ne peux pas le secouer
j'aime le j'aime trop le truc marshall américain ouais
cette robe anna sonora hey je
suis ian euh ouais pour l'
équipe de livestrong bond trigger je suis fan du
pass euh backstage
ouais je voulais juste  pour voir si je pouvais participer
à l'émission donc je suis fan
[Musique]
et puis de milan san remo tout le monde
se dirige vers le nord pour une autre grande
course d'une journée c'est la
classique pavée la plus célèbre et c'est celle qui
compte le plus  c'est l'enfer du
nord paribubay
pairu bay est spécial pour de nombreuses raisons,
mais pas des moindres bien sûr les pavés
qu'ils disent que l'armée de napoléon est piétinée sur
les mêmes pierres que les coureurs traversent maintenant
les pistes de la ferme comme aller au combat
c'est une sorte de fou  course d'aventure
il n'y a que 50 000 pavés sur 250 000,
donc cela semble très simple jusqu'à ce que vous alliez
essayer de le monter. Les fourches des gens cassent des
roues ou des pneus crevés arriveront,
des choses tomberont par elle ne savait jamais que vous
aviez sur des vélos tout le monde prie pour la pluie
sauf le  les coureurs bien sûr si c'est une
course sèche alors tu es totalement plongé
dans la poussière euh et la foule y va juste
pour voir le carnage c'est aussi simple que
ça
la base poudreuse convient euh
ça convient à un homme très dur
le gros homme belge sur place était  était
le belge tom bowner alors qu'il s'aligne
pour l'arrivée maintenant il égale le record
de quatre victoires de roger de vlaming
un autre grand cycliste belge et tom
pourrait en avoir un peu plus en lui pourtant il est
grand et il est fort mais il est mais il a
aussi le  intelligent et il a beaucoup de
confiance en lui et vous savez quand vous
traversez les pavés, les gars
meurent juste sa volonté les noms des
coureurs qui ont gagné piru bay sont sur les
murs des douches
et c'est là qu'ils les mettent  la course
disait que tout le monde déteste la course et
tout le monde veut gagner
[Musique]
quand tu penses à pararoo bay tu penses
aux guerriers du sport et tu
penses à matthew heyman c'est un gars qui
a commencé la course 13 fois et l'a fait jusqu'à
la fin  ligne à chaque fois que
mon
pire ou le plus mémorable roubaix était,
j'ai fini par rouler 10 minutes derrière le
dernier groupe par moi-même pendant environ 100 km
et
j'ai même nettoyé une dame sur l'une des
dernières sections parce que personne ne s'attendait à ce que
plus de coureurs
les traversent  Je fais tous mes bagages et je rentre à la maison
et
oui, donc je veux dire que j'ai terminé bon dernier et
10 minutes derrière le dernier dernier
[Musique]
Je suis tombé amoureux de la course assez
tôt,
plus j'ai avancé dans ma carrière que
plus  j'ai
aimé le faire et
ouais c'est juste que la relation
s'est épanouie,
continuez toujours à rouler quoi qu'il arrive, ça
vaut la peine d'aller au vélodrome parce
qu'aucune autre course où vous n'arrivez et ne finissez sur
un vélodrome comme ça
[Musique]
ce tour est toujours émouvant
toi  sais que j'ai commencé avec une équipe une
banque de caoutchouc et c'était assez
militaire assez vieille école assez difficile
vous savez tout comme l'armée ils savent
que vous ferez ce que vous avez
dit parce que vous avez été un peu
battu  et puis tu t'intègres dans le
système
j'ai déménagé dans une sorte de
logement étudiant donc c'était juste une
cuisine commune et
j'avais une petite chambre et une douche c'était
seul
tu es tu as 17 ans de l'autre
côté de  le monde tu ne parles pas la
langue les gens peuvent te sourire toute la journée
mais si tu ne comprends pas ce qu'ils
disent tu es assez isolé quand tu
fermes la porte et il n'y a pas de bruit et
c'est juste toi
et c'est quand  tu penses à la maison
j'étais assez déprimé la plupart du temps je
suppose que maman et papa se sont un peu inquiétés pour moi
parce que tu sais je suppose qu'ils
ont vu les signes d'un peu de dépression
ouais j'en suis arrivé au point où je n'étais pas
Bien sûr, je pouvais faire comme si c'était le
gars qui finissait à chaque fois que je prenais
cette décision que j'allais être une
bonne aide
et peut-être ouais peut-être qu'en regardant en arrière, ce
n'était pas vous savez que c'était une option un peu plus sûre
qu'il est  un super domestique tellement incroyable qu'il
n'était pas un gagnant il était un super
assistant maintenant l'équipe sky a décidé de prendre
la responsabilité de mettre la
pression sur je pense qu'il y avait un rabais
là-bas avec sky et j'ai fait beaucoup de
travail et puis vous savez  je me suis retrouvé
devant beaucoup de gars pour qui je roulais
et c'est deviné quand je sais que je
pensais qu'il était peut-être temps de changer et
d'aller dans une nouvelle équipe
le rôle d'un domestique dans une course comme
pararoo bay est de  protégez votre leader pour
les maintenir dans la bonne position avant de
frapper les sections pav8 et la plus
redoutée pas célèbre la plus redoutée
est la forêt d'arenberg le premier
vrai secteur de mauvaises routes il vient après
environ 100 kilomètres de course une fois
qu'ils '  re au-dessus de ce passage à niveau qui
entre dans la forêt,
vous venez de vous frapper à des vitesses si rapides
approchant 70 kilomètres à près de 50
miles à l'heure alors qu'ils entrent dans la
tranche, il fait euh deux kilomètres et demi de
long, la course a peut-être
commencé avec deux sous-coureurs mais il
sort avec peut-être 50 à 100 coureurs encore
à Perry Bay entrer est euh
c'est assez effrayant euh
tu sais j'ai vu des gars allongés là avec
des jambes cassées et des choses comme ça d'accord
qu'est-ce qui
secoue l'étranger
c'est une longue ligne droite  et
un divisé tout de suite et
c'était grisha yanuzka qui l'a mal jugé
totalement intrinsèquement ce sport est
dangereux n'est-ce pas je veux dire si vite
euh si désespéré d'obtenir ce résultat les gars
sont prêts à prendre ces risques il faut
beaucoup de courage pour lancer  plongez-vous dans
ces finales de sprint et
certaines de ces descentes,
nous sommes tous tellement concentrés sur le résultat final
et la grande
chose vers laquelle tout le monde se dirige,
mais parfois
des choses horribles se produisent
[Musique]
certaines personnes disent ouais d'accord cycle disent qu'elles
peuvent souffrir et  ils peuvent rouler toute la journée et
des trucs comme ça mais ce n'est pas du foot
vous ne vous frappez pas
essayez de sauter d'une voiture à 70k par heure
sur le bitume voyez comment vous tirez
les cyclistes sont les athlètes les plus durs du
sport
et je crois que vous  pourrait se casser une
clavicule en faisant du vélo et
rouler le lendemain parce qu'ils font
tout en disant stop c'est
ridicule mais d'un autre côté je pense
qu'il ne faut qu'une petite voix dans le
dos de votre tête disant arriver à l'arrivée
peut-être que ce n'est pas comme  mauvais comme vous pensez
s'arrêter et l'empêcher de peser
plus que de rouler avec une clavicule cassée,
j'ai eu les plus grands
moments de mauvaise sensation de chauve-souris quand je
n'ai pas vraiment regardé et que je viens
juste de commencer à recevoir des messages
et puis je peux  Je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe réellement et je ne peux pas le dire de
mes propres yeux, donc ce sont les parties les plus
difficiles pour moi,
donc
je suis dans l'équipe de Colombie
à cause de cette course
et j'écrase une strat pour
un signal
un signal de transition
et  la tête sur l'épaule,
je ne me souviens pas de l'accident,
bien que
le problème ait commencé pendant la
période de récupération après cela, lorsqu'il est devenu évident
qu'il n'avait aucun mouvement dans son bras de
ce côté, il est devenu évident qu'il
avait une lésion nerveuse importante pour
bien  trois nerfs différents autour de son
épaule je visite 10 médecins
et un seul me
dit que
tu peux en récupérer neuf dis moi que
tu dois prendre l'
assurance
et tu oublies que tu peux
à nouveau faire du vélo
il
sait qu'il
est retourné en colombie où il
a consulté un chirurgien là-bas
et ils
ont décidé qu'ils feraient une
greffe de nerfs
et donc ils ont transplanté un nerf de
sa jambe inférieure et ont fait trois greffes de nerf
autour de son épaule vers les
muscles euh l'innervation des
muscles qui ne fonctionnaient pas
euh et c'est une chose assez courageuse  faire
à un jeune homme
relativement peu de temps après un incident comme
celui-ci
dans une situation comme celle-ci avec vos
vrais amis
et les vrais amis c'est
maman papa mon frère
et le médecin ont
fait l'opération  comme les
costumes pour les candidatures olympiques de londres, donc
cela impliquait comme 138 athlètes et
tout le monde était comme une prima donna
tout le monde était comme tendu je devais faire des
costumes pour comme tony blair qui m'a fait
attendre six heures avant que je puisse le mesurer
ne ferait pas ça  encore une fois euh ce que c'est
au bord vert tout d'abord c'était
comme comment créez-vous réellement une sorte
de costume pour ces gars que
je n'avais même probablement jamais acheté une paire
de chaussures et encore moins un costume c'était juste
décontracté c'était comme  un groupe de potes
s'amuse bien il y a
28 coureurs dans l'équipe mais seuls
neuf d'entre eux obtiennent une place au tour de
france donc il y a beaucoup de pression
en début de saison pour essayer d'obtenir votre
place il y en a qui savent dès
le départ  tout début qu'ils iront
mais il y en a beaucoup mais c'est leur
rêve d'enfant
vous savez en 1903 quand ils voulaient
lancer un grand défi pour les
sportifs français pour vendre
des journaux personne n'aurait imaginé que cela
deviendrait le plus grand
événement sportif annuel  dans le monde
et le tour de france maintenant en juillet, c'est
quand tout le monde planifie ses vacances et
tous les coureurs espèrent pouvoir participer au
tour de france
comme le tennis a le grand chelem
le cyclisme a les grands tours et le
tour de france domine
c'est le saint  le graal
n'a pas d'importance le cours
tout le monde y va 100
bien les premières années du pass backstage
étaient très amusantes parce que très peu de
structure
donc c'était facile de sortir et de
s'amuser et littéralement de
pisser dessus à peu près tout
euh, nous avions amené Stevens des forces spéciales
pour conduire des choses aujourd'hui et il a dit que si je
ne mets pas l'un des garçons dans le frein,
je vais laver les voitures,
donc mon conseil numéro un pour venir à la
tournée comme  un fan prenez votre vélo une des
grandes montagnes ressentez ce que les cyclistes
ressentent vraiment entrez dedans ces gens
ont suivi le dernier conseil et devinez
ce que vous allez faire le vip
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le succès menant à juillet  peut
sortir par la fenêtre
si vous ne roulez pas bien dans le tour de
france parce que le monde se concentre sur le
tour de france ils ne connaissent pas
milan san rimi ou la baie de paris au même
niveau allez allez
il va  gagnez, attendez, allez,
non, aucun conducteur ne l'a,
nous frappons à la porte tout
le temps et nous tuons à chaque
sprint en nous tuant pour du brillant et
vous savez que les choses ne fonctionnaient tout simplement pas
ouais c'était juste un fou  tournée tu sais que
beaucoup de jeunes enfants là-bas ne savent pas
faire du vélo
tu sais
juste beaucoup d'inexpérience beaucoup de
désespoir beaucoup de nerfs
tu sais je pense que tout le monde a juste besoin de se
détendre la pilule
je pense quand nous devenions si  sur le point d'
obtenir un résultat dans ces courses, cela a
probablement
motivé les coureurs, mais cela a rendu la
direction plus désespérée et c'est à ce
moment-là que les décisions ont été
prises de s'engager à rouler devant pendant
de longues périodes pour ramener
des échappées pour des victoires d'étape  et tout ce qu'on
faisait c'était de brûler des
allumettes je me sens comme de la merde
a sa chance, hé,
vous roulez toujours pour moi, hé, j'espère que les
gars vont bien, nous roulons pour l'équipe,
vous tentez votre chance et les autres
prennent la leur aussi,
il n'y a pas de pression brillante,
pourquoi écrivons-nous sans personne  nous aider
hé nous ne pouvons contrôler personne d'autre mec
[Musique]
une chose que j'ai remarquée au cours de la dernière heure
est euh
les garçons sont plus motivés que jamais c'est que
ça n'a pas encore eu un très euh euh effet
[Musique]
il y a 22  les équipes du tour de france
il y a 21 étapes jeu d'acclamations musicales
quelqu'un va manquer et vous avez
des sprinters là-dedans qui gagnent plusieurs
étapes et ils étaient l'un de ceux
qui se sont retrouvés sans chaise quand ils sont
arrivés sur les champs-elysées
donc  nous avons fait cela juste avant de perdre
un peu de site papier cam [ __ ] christian
meyer et euh daniel l'année avant que nous
ayons eu l'équipe sur la route euh j'ai fait le
211 ici avec l'
équipe nationale australienne tour de lavanya signifie tour
du  la future avenue est future et donc
ce sont les enfants du futur j'ai pu
voir un stairman l'a vu sur le podium que
nous avions quand
certains de nos garçons avaient
aussi du succès donc à partir de ce moment-là
j'ai en quelque sorte ouais quand je regardais
à travers  résultats, je viens de remarquer que son nom
apparaît et c'était vraiment très
agréable de dire oh c'est ce petit
gars qui a remporté le 211 ici, donc ce n'est pas
surprenant qu'esteban chavez dès qu'il
a mis son nom sur la liste des gagnants, il
allait être un homme  que tout le monde voulait
signer d'abord j'ai remarqué que ses résultats de course
avaient disparu je suis allé un
peu plus loin nous avons contacté
son manager son manager a expliqué la
situation qu'il avait cette
mauvaise chute lui a vraiment fait mal à l'épaule et
l'opération ne s'est pas déroulée donc  eh bien,
il a eu une belle carrière jusqu'au moment
de son accident et pourquoi pas euh voyons
si nous pouvons le mettre en contact avec lui
il m'appelle
parle moi en espagnol
hey
je suis nilla stefans
donc je suis australien je viens de  l'
équipe oreca green age va te faire
[ __ ]
c'est non ce n'est pas bon pour les blagues je suis mauvais
donc si tu sais que tu es évidemment neil
stephen parce que junior parle
anglais
je euh ces premiers appels téléphoniques je suppose
avec le stairman
j'ai vraiment commencé à le connaître comme  un
gars en tant que personne mais je voulais vraiment
commencer cette relation personnelle pour
voir comment les choses se passaient ce que
nous allons faire à l'avenir et
déterminer comment nous allons le ramener en
europe pour évaluer son  blessure
l'armée est totalement morte
mais chaque matin quand je suis debout
c'est facile tu dis ouais je vais rester ici
et à la maison
mais je suis un pas
pour mon rêve pour esther dans le monde
pour faire cet euro pour à travers le tour de
france
euh
[Music]
est
mais je pense que dans tous les temps,
d'accord en septembre, je dois le faire
parce que ma vie peut changer
la lumière dans la finale du tunnel
est orica
la première fois que nous nous sommes rencontrés physiquement
était le jour
de  septembre
quand euh
on a eu un médecin de l'équipe un kiné
de l'équipe et moi-même on a dû
le rencontrer
aller derrière lui sur le vélo et évaluer
s'il allait pouvoir rouler pour
nous euh trois mois plus tard
et il est  si jeune quand il est
arrivé pour la première fois, il avait des bandes sur les dents et Matt
White est entré et il parlait aux
autres gars et
il a pratiquement ignoré Esteban
et je réfléchissais bien et donc j'ai dit
euh je les ai présentés l'un à l'autre et
et  le blanc est oh ouais ravi de vous rencontrer
et pourquoi il m'a dit après que je
pensais que c'était juste un enfant du coin qui venait
regarder ce qui se passait parce
qu'il avait l'air d'avoir environ 12 ans. maintenant sa poignée de main
c'était comme
serrer la main de quelqu'un qui a eu un
coup tu sais que c'est un gamin dont la carrière
est en jeu et euh il doit
jouer contre euh devant des gens
qu'il n'a jamais rencontrés avant
l'expression qu'il se tirait
bien tu sais comment c'était il est très
euh tu sais d'emblée et  euh
il était très factuel à propos de
tout ça tu sais c'est bon
esteban c'est ce qu'on va faire et c'est ce qu'on
veut voir
et allons-y faisons-le
[Musique]
il a roulé pendant un petit moment et je  sachez
qu'il était vraiment nerveux parce qu'il
roulait aussi durement qu'il le pouvait, il s'est levé
du siège, mais quand il s'est levé du
siège, j'ai remarqué qu'il avait triché, il a
poussé vers l'avant et vers le haut,
il ne s'est pas simplement levé du siège alors  je
savais que son bras n'était pas génial
[Musique]
mon conseil à l'équipe à ce moment-là était que
vous ne pouvez vraiment pas affronter ce gars jusqu'à ce qu'il
y ait au moins
un signe que le nerf se
remet en place shane a dit hé c'est un
risque
toi  Je sais qu'il a besoin d'aide, il ne s'en remettra peut-être pas,
il est jeune, mais il avait une bonne attitude face à
tout cela et euh,
je pense que c'est
important, ses valeurs sont ce qui, euh, le fait passer
à travers vous quand vous regardez
à travers ses yeux,
vous pouvez le voir vraiment.
personne affamée engagée qui voulait vraiment
réussir et voulait vraiment une
opportunité
ils ne disaient rien
juste parlé de courses et parlant
anglais et je sais que je n'ai rien compris
alors
oui
steve
me prenait comme ça comme hé
mec
bienvenue dans l'équipe
[ __ ] oui
j'ai essayé  pour un steak comme
merci mais à l'intérieur c'est
[Rires]
je prends le téléphone portable essayons ça
hé mon frère
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est
mon père
est content évidemment mais c'est plus
c'est ta deuxième opportunité dans la vie
donc
non non non non  profite de cette occasion et
mets à la poubelle tu te
concentres
le premier camp d'entraînement est difficile parce que
je ne peux pas parler en anglais je ne
comprends
rien va juste aux réunions et
[Rires]
nous traînons juste au premier camp d'entraînement
nous '  Je suis tous les deux nouveaux dans l'équipe, c'est mon
colocataire
et il est vraiment fier de ce travail.
Je l'aime bien. Sa mentalité,
il me
dit de me détendre beaucoup. Je ne sais pas pourquoi
nous nous sommes si bien entendus
si tôt.
m'a rencontré et m'a dit
tu sais qu'ils ont dit que ce gars australien
ses
cheveux sont comme ça il est tout droit sur la
ligne il doit être allemand donc je suis dans la
pièce comme seul
et il passe et il me regardera
et juste
tu sais  dis-moi allez allez alors [ __ ]
peut-être une réunion ou n'importe où et il a mis
tous ses vêtements et il a commencé à
marcher il a pensé bon sang que nous marchons
pendant un moment et il a essayé de m'attendre
et j'ai seulement dit oui mais ne comprenons
rien
nous  en fait, il est allé dans les magasins pour prendre un
café et il pensait que je disais qu'il
devait aller à une réunion d'équipe ou quelque chose comme ça,
donc il n'avait aucune idée de ce qui se passait
et il a juste souri tout au long des
deux premiers camps d'entraînement et
mais cela étant dit  il ne s'est pas à un
moment exclu du groupe il
n'avait aucune idée de ce qui se passait mais il avait
passé des heures assis avec nous
et il souriait quand tout le monde souriait
et on pouvait dire qu'il voulait faire
partie du  groupe qu'il ne voulait pas être
à l'extérieur
[Musique]
nous venons de peuples tribaux
faisant partie de groupes et de communautés
et je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous
cherchons encore à
faire partie d'un groupe qui fait
quelque chose de spécial
[Musique]
la tournée 2012  de france où nous sommes allés si
près tant de fois nous n'avions pas encore atteint ce que
nous voulions donc nous
avions vraiment quelque chose à prouver dans cette tournée et
bien toute la préparation est faite maintenant
nous sommes au début de la première étape euh ça va
être une étape passionnante et
très tendue
et la 100e édition du tour de
france s'éloigne de porto vecchio
destination bastille
bien est-ce le jour où onika green
age remporte la victoire ils ont vraiment
voulu que la première équipe australienne
participe  dans le tour de france
alors qu'ils parcourent maintenant les vignobles
ici et ils auront besoin de tout l'abri
qu'ils peuvent obtenir maintenant est littéralement sur les
plages de la mer méditerranée
et c'était ça se développait en une
finition incroyable c'était vraiment et
ils '  re environ 20 20 miles sur 32
kilomètres encore à parcourir, ils l'ont
poussé 16 secondes l'écart je suis arrivé à la
ligne d'arrivée et il n'y avait pas de bus d'équipe
j'ai dit que nous avions besoin du bus uniquement pour l'
exercice pr et il a dit  neil où est le
bus j'étais dans la deuxième voiture de
la course et j'ai dit que les bus à l'
hôtel c'est juste en bas de la route depuis l'
arrivée j'ai passé quelques appels téléphoniques
et j'ai parlé au chauffeur du bus qui a dit oui
je peux obtenir  là, il
est devenu impératif que ce tout
nouveau bus très cher soit à la
ligne d'arrivée avec tous les autres,
alors nous sommes arrivés là-bas et
comme nous conduisions, il était tard,
mais l'organisation a dit de l'amener
dépêchez-vous d'y aller
don  ne ralentissez pas parce que la course approche,
les organisateurs pensaient que
tout le monde était dedans, mais lorsque le dernier bus
est passé, ils laissent tomber la
ligne d'arrivée, ils le treuillent et
Gary le chauffeur, je veux dire qu'il n'était
là que pour quelques  jours de remplissage, ce
n'était pas son bus à conduire,
donc il est déjà nerveux
et nous nous dirigeons vers l'
arche d'arrivée, elle a en quelque sorte dû lever les yeux j'ai
dit non, elle a raison, ils vous ont fait
signe que cela conviendra à ma femme était
très excité  voici le bus
et la prochaine chose c'était comme si le titanic
heurtait l'iceberg
et j'étais assis derrière Gary et j'ai
presque dépassé le guidon et je me suis
allongé sur lui et j'ai
vu cette arche se pencher en avant et les
gens en dessous
dans l'ensemble, le poteau
a commencé à basculer vers l'endroit où nous étions
assis
si nous quittons l'air soudainement, c'est parce que
les bannières viennent de toucher ma boîte de commentaires,
il était si proche de l'arrivée que
tous les photographes étaient là pour se
préparer car vous savez le sprint du groupe
ils voient tous  en ce moment, toutes ces
caméras apparaissent toutes à l'unisson
assis à l'avant du bus c'est
comme si vous étiez assis dans un bocal à poissons cette
grande grande fenêtre en verre j'ai vu les caméras
levées et j'ai sauté de mon siège avant
sur le siège arrière mais ils  je ne pouvais
plus me voir je pensais oh c'est un
désastre absolu ça a juste empiré
après ça
maintenant on entend la radio de la course
et qu'ils organisent une nouvelle arrivée
ils auront l'arrivée au sprint pour la
fin de la course à trois  kilomètres pour aller
bien nous avons regardé où ils ont dit que c'était
dans un virage 8k à parcourir 7k à parcourir et je
le regarde à l'écran et ils l'ont
enroulé ils sont à fond ils
n'obtiendront pas  ce bus sort de là
dans les 10 prochaines minutes six cinq et
nous ne sommes toujours pas sortis de dessous cette
chose oh merde moi-même
de savoir que nous allions potentiellement
organiser le plus grand événement sportif annuel
au monde
mon bus
il avait un  effondrement
oh je viens de dire ressaisissez-vous je
ne pouvais pas arrêter de trembler
j'ai pensé
pendant quelques secondes
que nous allions être la seule équipe
jamais expulsée du tour de france
pour rien à voir avec le dopage
ce n'était pas avant ce local  un français
a crié de l'autre côté de la bannière hé
pourquoi ne laissez-vous pas l'air sortir des
pneus
alors que nous parlons le bus recule sur
la ligne d'arrivée et maintenant que vont-
ils faire parce qu'ils pourraient bien s'en
sortir ils l'obtiennent  en bas de la route,
vous parlez de pression, je veux dire que le
gars avait l'inverse de ce bus sur 180
mètres de poche inversée
et il avait environ quatre minutes et demie
pour le faire
en quelques minutes moins de quelques
minutes, la course s'est déroulée  la ligne
droite de la maison et il a utilisé la
ligne d'arrivée normale
quand ils ont juste tiré le bus, c'était
en quelque sorte parmi la foule derrière les
barrières, tout le monde huait le bus et
cela ressemblait à un épisode des
simpsons ou des gens avec des fourches
venant obtenir  nous
un cluster
mais pourquoi il a changé ce [ __ ] de programme
qu'ils nous ont dit hier
c'est mieux tu n'as pas le meilleur pour
finir c'est mieux il a [ __ ] de changé
le programme je sais maintenant je vais avoir de la
logistique majestueuse merde mon pote
[Musique]
nous  je dois faire face à la musique pour les organisateurs de la course
j'essaie juste de je dois essayer je vais
essayer d'arrêter mais je ne sais pas que nous
ne pouvons pas travailler vous voulez vous garer ou je vais
essayer de  mais
je suis un peu stressé
[Musique]
j'ai dit que nous ferions mieux de gagner une étape
sinon nous allons jeter les clés
parce que je ne veux pas être connu
comme ayant écrasé un bus
qui est même devenu un peu  plus de
pression pour faire quelque chose dans l'une
des étapes,
donc c'était l'autre chose que la climatisation
a été cassée parce que lorsque nous avons frappé l'
arc, il a frappé directement sur l'
unité de climatisation, aucun climatiseur n'a pu
le réparer,
il faisait chaud comme  l'enfer dans le sud de la
france là-bas en juillet alors oui nous
allions au début de l'étape
euh
dégoulinant de sueur les
mecs faisaient tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
ils s'éventaient avec le
livre de course ouvrant le frigo et le congélateur
et se tenant juste devant  et
donc ce n'était pas une récupération idéale pour les garçons
[Applaudissements]
vous obtenez le plus gros fromage du
spectacle
en fait nous sommes arrivés bien trop tard pour la
course
[Musique]
nous manquions de temps
personne ne voudrait avoir le temps de se réchauffer  monter
correctement n'était pas comme une grande chose comme je
courais pour des équipes italiennes comme ouais ce
serait comme euh
un gros problème comme les gens vont paniquer
nous n'avons pas vérifié le parcours le
matin les gars sont allés faire un peu un
tour
nous  a fait un tour avant le début de la course,
il n'y avait pas le temps de devenir
nerveux,
les garçons ont fait leur truc sur
les entraîneurs à domicile et nous sommes partis, donc nous
avons eu une bonne chance d'
entrer dans le maillot jaune, espérons-le, mais c'est
la compétition comme  eh bien,
le maillot jaune revient à la personne
qui mène la course au général, donc celui qui
a le moins de temps accumulé pour la
distance parcourue jusque-là
[Musique]
nous savions que nous devions commencer vite
c'est un bon début les gars qui recherchent le
sommet autour de ces virages très bien d'
accord les gars 100 mètres vous avez le
cœur coin gauche puis pavés maintenant
c'est orica bord vert qui semblait
défier le temps du fermier oméga pas
rapide
nous avons commencé vite mais nous étions en retard à
mi-chemin
maintenant ce  pourrait être le temps qui pourrait
durer tout l'après-midi
il y avait un ou deux coureurs qui se
débattaient un peu
re tu es
comme oh tu continues de penser que tu dois
aller plus vite allez
je n'oublierai jamais ce virage que ce
cygne que j'ai pris c'était juste que je n'avais pas l'impression
que c'était l'un des plus rapides que j'aie
jamais été  vous avez littéralement eu l'impression que votre
casque allait être soulevé de votre
tête vous alliez si vite que
lorsque vous êtes sur une autoroute, vous
tenez votre tête par la fenêtre de la
voiture comme
lorsque vous avez tout le monde à un très bon
niveau il n'y a pas  augmentation du rythme, il
n'y a pas de changement,
c'est comme si cette chose fluide parfaite
65k par heure n'est pas un problème
s'ils ont réussi celui-ci, ce
sera un énorme coup, je pense qu'ils peuvent voir
l'horloge maintenant alors qu'ils se battent ici et
le font tourner chez les gars  mettez-le dedans allons jusqu'au bout
ça va être désespérément proche ils
savent à quel point ils regardent les
visages alors qu'ils se dirigent vers la ligne
ils ont cinq six secondes cinq
secondes quatre trois ils sont assis alors
qu'ils  hit
[Music]
est-ce qu'il va être le prochain australien à
porter le myogen il doit attendre un
peu mais ouais mec on
n'oubliera jamais comme ces quelques minutes
d'attente
et ça pourrait être un bon moment ça va
être très très  rapide en effet alors que
décrire l'adrénaline qui
traversait le groupe était incroyable
alors qu'ici à l'écran on voit
arriver les anciens chefs d'équipe
du tour de france et le
leader individuel qui les ramène ici
en maillot jaune  mais maintenant c'est fini
et les prochains miles du tour de france
seront un australien et ce sera celui de
simon garen alors qu'il se prépare maintenant pour
le jaune
[Musique] c'est
juste le moment le plus doux du maillot
c'est comme un rêve ici j'ai dû
me pincer  pour dire hé, vous savez comme euh
des sucettes bouillies qui s'écrasent euh des pâtes,
vous savez des chocolats et
[Musique]
vous savez que vous pouvez avoir de superbes
balades en équipe qui permettront aux individus de
gagner mais d'avoir une équipe de gars qui
n'étaient pas les favoris et puis  pour faire apparaître
simon garen dans le maillot jaune
c'était un rêve devenu réalité et euh j'ai
la chair de poule en y pensant
c'était celui que la plupart des mammifères les
hommes d'âge moyen et le lycra qu'ils ont lié
à ça tu as quelques gars là-dedans
qui étaient à la fin de la trentaine ainsi que
quelques-uns des jeunes australiens qui y
parvenaient ont coché toutes les cases
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous ne nous attendions pas à le gagner
et puis évidemment nous l'avons gagné et puis
simon était  en maillot jaune et c'était
énorme pour l'équipe c'était tellement
excitant vous savez et évidemment il était
alors un peu dans un monde différent
parce qu'il était tellement bombardé par la presse
c'était énorme c'est un immense honneur c'est un
énorme frisson vous savez  comme je l'ai dit, le
tour de france est considéré comme le summum
du sport, vous savez, j'étais vraiment en train de
m'imprégner un peu
et je n'étais pas si préoccupé par ce qui
se passait et j'appréciais juste d'être dans le
maillot jaune
[Musique]
alors nous '  je suis dans la voiture et gary vient de faire
les présentations du maillot jaune il arrive
et la première chose qu'il dit est que je vais
donner le maillot jaune à daryl
demain si simon gehrens a été le
michael jordan de cette équipe
daryl olympia a été le scottie pippen
vous regardez tous les résultats d'erika
et daryl est là il fait partie du
train de tête pour l'un des sprinters comme il l'
était pour simon au tour de france il est
là dans les longues courses d'une journée comme
milan san remo soutenant la victoire de simon garen
celui-là, il n'y a pas de course sur la
planète que daryl olympia ne peut pas jouer un
rôle pour aider oracle à gagner
qu'olympia était toujours au niveau du temps
avec simon et j'ai dit à daryl que diriez-
vous de savoir que nous terminons à temps
aujourd'hui nous essayons et pas le  avant d'avoir des
ennuis et ensuite je reviendrai
tu finiras devant moi et ensuite
tu pourras prendre le maillot
parce que je pensais en quelque sorte que tu sais que
j'aurais pu potentiellement tenir le maillot
pendant quatre jours euh je n'allais jamais
tenir tout le chemin jusqu'à paris euh et c'était
une expérience qui a changé la vie juste d'avoir
ce maillot alors
j'ai pensé pourquoi ne pas le donner à un pote
et changer sa vie aussi
[Applaudissements]
ça pourrait être des jetons ici
ça prend un gros  pilote de partager
la gloire avec ses coéquipiers, donc bien
sûr, je suis toujours reconnaissant
pour ce geste
[Applaudissements]
vous serez dans ces livres comme le tout
premier pas seulement d'un pays d'un
continent comment cela fait-il de vous  Sentez-vous oh
magie, euh, pour
pouvoir même dire que j'ai porté
le maillot jaune, vous savez, encore moins dire
que j'ai écrit l'histoire de l'
Afrique du Sud, euh
et pour le moment, je ne pense à rien
au sommet,
je tout le monde juste  je pense que j'ai inclus un
peu de larme le jour parce que c'est
un moment émouvant dans le
sport parce que nous savons tous ce que cela signifie
pour simon guerres de mettre ce maillot
sur les épaules de daryl olympia, il
a été accueilli avec incrédulité
en particulier par beaucoup  des ex-pros qui
sont dans la case des commentaires
qui
pensent du point de vue du
maillot jaune tu tiens ça aussi longtemps
que tu peux c'est sacré
la culture de l'équipe en est une qui
ce n'est pas grave pour nous je veux dire nous
tout c'est ce qu'on
fait l'un pour l'autre et tu
sais parce que tu es un grand nom alors oh
tu le mérites et c'est dans cette équipe
c'est comme si on faisait tous notre part pour que
chacun
ait sa chance et son opportunité
[Musique] je me
souviens de mon  papa vient de rentrer en
afrique du sud a invité tout le monde à la maison pour
faire une grande fête et ils m'ont téléphoné et
c'est ouais ces moments malheureusement
ne viennent pas trop souvent
quelques
milliers de ces guitares oracle green
edge brûlantes sur la route les
garçons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai apprécié les trucs ac dc parce que j'ai senti
dès que j'ai mis la perruque j'ai eu l'impression d'
avoir un déguisement et non  on
m'avait reconnu donc peu importe ce que
je faisais bien, j'ai en fait presque perdu mon travail
avec ce clip parce que ce qui
s'est passé est en Espagne, vous pouvez acheter
des feux d'artifice à peu près au comptoir,
alors nous avons pensé que vous saviez que nous
profiterons de  que ce à quoi nous ne nous attendions pas, c'est que
le feu d'artifice se fasse prendre sur le
banc du parc
sam bully était à environ un pied de
se faire arracher les jambes
du pass backstage apporte une nouvelle
dimension à la façon dont vous vendez le
cyclisme professionnel les gars sont
devenus des artistes et  nous savons à quel point
ils sont bons sur les vélos maintenant nous découvrons
à quel point ils sont bons en tant que personnes et voyons
les personnages se développer
Rires]
mais c'est non ce n'est pas comme un
moment sérieux tu sais triste
toujours amusant parce que c'est australien donc
les australiens sont comme ça c'est une
culture
les gens disent que tu as fait un
clip pendant la grande tournée ils sont genre
qu'as-
tu fait  que c'est devenu
une très bonne distraction, vous savez, et une
distraction saine
parce que vous savez que vous ne pensiez pas seulement à
quel point c'était difficile et que
vous réfléchissez à comment pouvons-nous faire
autre chose pour la vidéo, peut-être sur
scène et debout sur le  podium et
faire l'appel moi peut-être et pointer vers
dan jones dans la foule maintenant je suis
intéressé
regardez je n'ai jamais vraiment été ça jusqu'à ce
que si vous revenez à la
vidéo appelez-moi peut-être vous me verrez en
soudure de sevrage de [ __ ]  la science et nous ne voulions pas
faire cela et nous n'avons vraiment pas
bien les clips vidéo ont amené l'
interaction des fans au niveau supérieur et le
meilleur exemple que nous ayons aurait
été giorgio ce fan italien qui vient de
décider un jour  va marcher dans
notre bus c'est ton jour oui oui
le meilleur jour de ma journée aujourd'hui
ouais vraiment vraiment
saint georgia le saint patron de
greenwich quel est ton moment préféré dans les coulisses
ou tu te sens peut-être la
21e étape
de l'année italia l'année dernière
quand je suis heureux de
venir aux danses d'escalade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
d'accord d'accord georgio bien content que nous
ayons pu réaliser ton rêve et rencontrer
les garçons pendant que tu es ici, nous pouvons
te servir un café ou toutes les boissons que tu aimerais
euh  non merci parce que mes cheveux
ouais,
vous savez, nous pouvons voir
ce qui se passe dans les coulisses
quand ils ne sont pas
euh dans la course ou qu'ils ne sont pas en
conférence de presse ou pas dans une interview en quelque sorte
voir leurs personnalités
voir cette émotion vraiment brute, mais cela
ouvre vraiment la porte au côté humain
de la course et c'est ce que ces gars
ont fait un excellent travail avec ça ouais
pour les gars qui ont fait rebecca avant
après les flux quand c'est complètement nouveau
juste euh
faites attention là ce n'est pas une course
aujourd'hui c'est un disque
[Musique]
je connais Maddie depuis longtemps depuis que
nous sommes enfants et évidemment
vous avez une impression je pense de l'
extérieur et puis quand vous travaillez avec lui
vous obtenez  une autre impression mais c'est un
perfectionniste et il demande
énormément à lui-même et j'avais dit que tu sais que je
veux être le leader de ces courses et et je
saurais tu parler à shane et et
whitey et le reste de la  le personnel et maintenant
c'était l'heure du jeu maintenant je devais
marcher sur la marche dans laquelle il avait sa première grande
chance d'être un leader dans son équipe et
il voulait qu'il veuille prouver ce qu'il
pouvait faire nous avions une équipe si jeune et
puis nous  avait heyman c'était un peu ce que c'était, c'était
comme si ces jeunes gars
apprenaient et puis il y a un gars plus âgé
de qui nous pouvions apprendre,
donc l'idée est euh pour matthew
ce
sam tu resteras autour de matthew à partir de
nouveau
si quelque chose
arrive tu toujours  tu es toujours là
ils ne le font pas ça ne veut pas dire que tu dois
t'asseoir dans le vent toute la journée avec lui autour de
lui
si tu t'arrêtes pour l'abîme tu es
toujours là avec ton chef
fabian ne va pas le chevaucher
jusqu'à  un groupe sur la route il
ne va pas commencer à rouler à l'avant
sur la route il attendra juste une
longue et longue section pavée va
se remettre dans la course
tu as l'un des gars les plus expérimentés
du peloton ici  il est dans le top
10 euh au cours des trois dernières années deux
fois au cours des trois dernières années,
donc il n'y a pas de meilleur gars à écouter
qu'un gars de votre équipe une énorme
différence entre être un domestique
avec votre seule responsabilité est de faire
ce qu'on vous dit  à faire pour aller dans
certains dans un type de rôle de leadership
où vous devez ensuite donner l'
exemple montrer le chemin,
puis vous arrivez au jour de la course et vous réalisez
que tout le monde va rouler pour
vous et vous essayez de tourner  de toute
cette énergie
paribubo est probablement l'une des courses les plus
stressantes pour les mécaniciens
en raison de l'éventail plus large de travail que nous
devons faire quand ils s'écrasent vous devez
y arriver le plus vite possible vous savez que
vous êtes déjà en retard pour y arriver  et
ensuite vous devez décider s'ils ont
besoin d'un vélo ou d'un changement de roue afin de
créer beaucoup plus de stress car
beaucoup plus d'équipement est endommagé sur
les routes accidentées,
c'est en fait plus rapide si vous le faites simplement
comme si vous sautiez encore  sortez rapidement de la voiture
et vous vous précipitez aussi vite que
possible sur le vélo, mais si vous essayez de le faire
très vite en essayant de gagner du temps,
vous finissez par tâtonner et vous empirez.
Je suis dans la baie du Pérou cet après-midi, mais
ce  est tomica en personne c'est un
cycliste professionnel fort il roule sur
les pavés probablement mieux que
quiconque dans le sport du cyclisme professionnel
la quantité d'
énergie mentale et je pense que les gars se fatiguent
autant mentalement que physiquement
vous savez que vous êtes  en regardant cette roue,
vous recherchez un danger, vous recherchez, vous êtes
constamment en train d'analyser
et de faire ces petits
ajustements en une
fraction de seconde  kilomètres jusqu'à la section suivante
quand nous étions trois gars là-bas
je pense qu'il devait rester environ 30
gars et la pause revenait
s'ils se sont assis je ne sais pas environ
15 secondes vous savez 10 secondes j'étais
comme de la merde je suis  tirer ce frein sur
mon propre bon travail mitch le meilleur j'avais
l'impression que c'était mon travail et j'étais
plus qu'heureux de le faire parce que je savais que
ces gars allaient donner 100 essais
et gagner la course non seulement pour obtenir un
résultat mais  pour essayer de gagner
[Applaudissements]
le paiement était sur la route, sa roue s'est
effondrée, c'était comme l'avant-dernier
secteur, donc c'était comme de la
frustration,
il a environ 300 mètres d'avance.
les meilleures éditions de cyclisme professionnel à fond que
nous ayons vues au cours des années
désolé que
vous montiez dans le bus et que
vous veniez de terminer vous êtes simplement heureux
d'avoir terminé un autre roubaix à peu
près et maddie est là-dedans vous ne
savez pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé  avec la
course et
Matty, tu sais
en euh en larmes un peu à l'arrière du
bus,
c'est sûr qu'il aurait senti qu'il se sentait un
gros euh comme s'il avait laissé tomber l'équipe, c'était que
c'était que la chance tu sais que
j'étais huitième  une fois est-ce que ça va être le
meilleur résultat de tous les temps tu es un peu comme oh
ne sois pas si dur avec toi-même maddie tu
sais l'année prochaine et tu regardes un peu
tu es comme si
je disais ça depuis 14
ans  et je manquais d'
opportunités euh tu sais j'avais l'impression que
tu sais qu'il n'en reste plus
beaucoup tu sais que nous
faisons une course de six heures et j'arriverai à
l'arrivée et cette nuit sera juste des
vidéos constantes de la course je  je serai juste
éveillé la nuit je ne m'endormirai pas c'est
comme pourquoi j'étais là pourquoi ai-je fait ça
et je vais juste le réanalyser encore et
encore
tu sais que je suis beaucoup plus à l'aise dans
cette position de  aider d'autres personnes
[Musique]
après l'
opération quand je recommence à conduire
en moto et le groupe dans les courses
j'ai peur dans les virages peut-être que j'ai un accident ou
peut-être que je souffre tellement et
il est possible que ces gars-là je ne puisse pas  je peux
faire le même niveau qu'avant
je ne pouvais pas
m'empêcher de penser qu'il manquait quelque chose et
euh
je suis allé chez le euh allé
chez le médecin nous avons commencé à parler de
dossiers d'entraînement sur les poids sur les
fréquences cardiaques et ce genre de choses et
et euh le  doc a dit oh je n'ai aucune
de ces informations a dit que voulez-vous dire
j'ai oublié
cette information esteban n'avait pas été
contesté et tout à fait délibérément
parce que nous essayions d'être très
prudent avec lui
mais il est venu le moment où il était temps de
mettre le pied à terre, vous pouviez encore voir qu'il
y avait tellement d'éléments de sa
vie et comment il
s'est appliqué au cyclisme
qui devaient être abordés pour qu'il
gagne au plus haut niveau et c'est
frustrant de voir ces gars quand ils
ne s'appliquent pas vraiment à eux-mêmes et et
ils ne tirent pas le meilleur parti d'
eux-mêmes je suis retourné à un coup de couteau et moi et
je lui ai dit mon pote comment vas-tu
et nous avons réalisé que c'était tu ne connais
que quelques kilos  capable de surpoids
et j'ai dit regarde tout ce que tu veux faire
c'est bon pour moi tu sais si tu
veux prendre si tu veux aller très
fort j'irai très fort mais si tu
veux juste traverser la vie ça
me va  Je traverserai la vie
moi-même
s'il
vous dit quelque chose
comme ça
peut-être qu'il a
été emprisonné
j'ouvre les
yeux
et dis que je dois travailler dur
parce qu'à ce moment je travaille dur mais j'ai
besoin de travailler plus dur
[Musique]
pour beaucoup ils regardent  à la vuelta en tant que
troisième grand tour c'est celui de la fin
de la saison donc pour certains c'est le saloon de la dernière
chance d'autres le voient comme leur
opportunité de briller pour la première fois
en termes de culture même si la
culture espagnole est quelque chose de
vraiment spécial  ils sont super détendus mais
super enthousiastes, c'est cool, calme
et recueilli jusqu'à ce que le peloton arrive
et ensuite vous voyez cette passion brute qui a le
flair espagnol et l'amour pour le sport et
ils aiment leur cyclisme et esteban a été
envoyé là-bas avec une opportunité mais aussi
avec attente  à cette époque, il avait
perdu du poids, euh, il ressemblait à un vrai
grimpeur, vous pouviez voir qu'il cochait tellement
de ces cases et qu'il était prêt à
être compétitif et je pense que c'est à
ce moment-là que le groupe a unanimement
pensé bien pourquoi ne pas lui donner  un coup
voyons comment il va en tant que chef d'équipe et
même des coureurs beaucoup plus expérimentés comme
matt hayman qui a vraiment eu sa
chance
en 2014 n'a pas pu faire face à cette pression
c'est une chose de se voir confier un
rôle de leadership dans une équipe mais ensuite  si vous avez
d'autres peurs derrière la
tête, pas seulement la peur de l'échec pour
esteban, c'était aussi la peur de s'écraser,
il devait affronter sa peur de front et voir
s'il pouvait la surmonter.
au monde espana 2015
euh en commençant ici à puerto vanus pour le
contre-la-montre d'une équipe,
donc j'ai dû travailler très dur en revenant
d'une blessure au tour de france juste
pour prendre le départ et euh j'ai joué
un rôle un peu différent de  aider ces
jeunes gars pour leurs domaines choisis de
la course
[Musique]
parcours mouvementé ce seront les gars
les plus grosses boules là-bas donc nous
allons tous y aller et lui donner une
chance
hé savez-vous comment commencer  vous
irez bien [ __ ], croyez-
vous
[Musique]
allons-y les gars
[Musique] allez les
gars ce n'est pas le [ __ ] de dernier
k allez les gars déchirons-le
[Musique]
pendant que la course avançait, vous pouviez voir
il a commencé à se détendre si votre leader a un
comportement détendu, cela se répand
dans tout le groupe et il
commençait à devenir évident qu'esteban
commençait vraiment à avoir une influence
sur cette équipe, le plus important est juste
de profiter de la balade profiter de
chaque jour quand  tu ne peux pas aller au vélo
dehors
parce que tu ne sais jamais ce qui s'est passé à
la finale
est revenu
ici les
gars
comment allez-vous mec hey je vais bien je vais bien
c'est un aujourd'hui mais je vais bien comment était ta
journée
jusqu'à présent alors  le bon
chris froome venait de
remporter son deuxième tour de france euh
mais c'est super de le voir au
verwalter
et mike turd alors qu'un fan de vélo disait où est
frami
et j'ai dit euh
regarde je m'en fous vraiment où est pour amy
mon pote je suis intéressé par cette dab sur ça a
continué à partir de là et puis il
m'a redemandé ouais mais nous avons entendu dire que nous
sommes de
[ __ ]
supposons qu'il pensait qu'il allait
attaquer il va faire quelque chose et j'ai
dit mon pote  je ne sais pas ouais on se fiche de
savoir où il était quelques jours plus tard
fermi est passé devant la voiture il a
ralenti un peu à côté de la voiture
je pensais que je racontais l'histoire hé
à travers moi
tu vois cette vidéo d'ici  l'autre
jour
la vidéo de l'autre jour
mon passager a dit où est frumi j'ai dit je sais
[ __ ] où est le cadre
il n'a pas aimé cette histoire aujourd'hui
c'est embarrassant et pas seulement que
tu parles au vainqueur du tour
de france il est attrapé  dans le vent,
il essaie de revenir dans le groupe,
il ne veut pas que vous lui mordilliez l'oreille
à propos de bonnes histoires et encore moins que oh
crocky à quoi pensiez-vous
oh [ __ ] hé m'a jeté nous n'avons pas terminé
l'histoire
peut-être l'un des  pires
histoires que vous avez partagées avec nous
une autre journée chaude les températures montent
jusqu'au milieu des années 30 la journée la plus chaude que
nous ayons eue tout au long de la course de cette année
et il y a le jeune colombien esteban
chavez qui n'a pas encore fait ses preuves
en tant que chef d'équipe dans cette  course jusqu'à présent
[Musique]
Matt Heyman était un peu le
bras droit d'Esteban pour la majorité
des welter il euh il me fait confiance il ne remet
rien en question je fais je suis toujours derrière
mon patron hey mec et il me demande toujours
comment tu te sens
ouais je me sens bien merci ce dont tu as besoin non
non je vais bien
15 minutes après ce que
tu ressens il est dérangé par la
montée sûrement grosse grosse vapeur en ville
qui pourrait en attraper quelques-uns aussi et
on y va et ça va  pour commencer à
faire mal j'ai dit ouais ça n'a pas été facile et
il m'a en quelque sorte regardé vraiment vraiment
patron a-t-il été si difficile qu'il semble que
ça va lui briser le cœur
parce que tant de gens ont un intérêt et
regardent l'urgence  derrière
à un moment près de la finale
les gars le grimpent
dites moi hé
regardez regardez tous les gars
tous les gars sont pleins de sel tous les gars
souffrent je souffre et tu me dis
tout le temps tu te sens bien
si tu te sens bien bonnes jambes aujourd'hui toi  peut
attaquer tu ne peux pas tu peux tu peux gagner
et il a décollé
et chavez y va mais cet homme
a une stature plus courte mais plus grande
[Musique]
quand nous avons tourné ce coin et c'était
vraiment très raide et ensuite steve
cummings il va  naviguez à côté de lui alors qu'il
arrive sur cette pente et écoutez
le rugissement d'approbation et il est toujours sur
le sexy oh regardez ça presque à l'
arrêt cummings
il est [ __ ] d'apparaître il est de retour et
parti
j'avais entendu à la radio le
gradateur de poursuite de dumoulin  des voies le pourchassant
le leader est parti après lui [ __ ]
c'est notre leader essayant de conserver
le moindre maillot quel super coup de poing
nous avons et tom dumas signifie que ça vient
sur
ce maillot
et tu commences à croire non
peut-être que tu es  retour oh
vraiment 800 mètres
oh [ __ ] de colline
[Musique]
oui
mais le plus grand appel de tous est le nom
de chavez ça sonne en bas des
montagnes et avec juste des desserts cet
homme va prendre la journée  il va
le prendre ici parmi la foule il est
extrêmement populaire
[Musique]
j'en ai marre d'être vieux tous ces jeunes
gars qui gagnent des courses
il est tout sourire et donc il devrait être
chavez gagne l'étape et chavez est le
nouveau leader de la course
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
euh [
euh
ouais il a résumé on a euh on a fait
un rêve il a fait un rêve et on
continue à rêver
heureux là profites-en merci
[Rires  ]
[Musique]
étranger
c'est la vie mec dans la vie tu as besoin de continuer à te
battre
et c'est sûr que
la dernière porte est la bonne
il se réveille tous les jours juste juste
heureux d'être en vie
et d'avoir quelqu'un comme ça dans ta chambre
si tu '  Je partage une chambre avec eux pendant trois
semaines et ils
vous disent juste chaque jour quelle belle
journée c'est c'est
plutôt agréable c'est assez humiliant
à tout âge, vous pouvez apprendre quelque chose de nouveau
de n'importe qui dans votre vie et
pour Matt Hayman voir le chemin  esteban a
fait face à cette pression en espagne
l'a probablement inspiré à lever la main
et à accepter la pression une fois de plus
peut-être une autre fois à
pararoo bay la course qui signifiait le plus
pour lui
ouais je fais du vélo avec des cadeaux ils
sont venus ici avec olivia  oliver nass et le
pilote local de pottermore 37
vont aussi très bien, mais certains disent peut-être qu'il
a
perdu un peu trop de poids oh nous avons eu
un accident de masse derrière un accident de masse derrière
plusieurs coureurs de bmc vers le bas
et quelques-uns d'entre eux n'ont pas l'air trop
bien  J'ai peur
qu'un pilote d'orica green edge
avec la taille du cadre,
vous deviez deviner
que c'est Matt Heyman mais nous attendrons de
jeter un coup d'œil
et en tant que pilote, vous savez
quand j'ai touché le sol, je savais que j'étais  Je ne me
suis pas levé, il n'avait pas l'air de
souffrir ou de crier ou de crier ou quoi que ce soit
comme si c'était comme cette
saison classique,
je veux juste monter dans la voiture de l'équipe, je
voulais, je ne voulais plus être là.
euh je savais que quelque chose n'allait pas
et tu sais que les médecins
viennent tu sais six à huit semaines et
je regarde mon téléphone six semaines c'est le
samedi avant roubaix
donc nous devrions avoir raison
et le médecin dit non tu as  aucune
chance tu sais vas-y doucement tu
sais
cette vie que tu as j'ai eu 100 blessures
avant de me casser des os avant
juste
tu sais pourquoi le pousser je ne pouvais pas y croire
ouais je savais qu'il était vraiment
bien  forme, il avait eu une très bonne
pré-saison, il mène les
classiques
peut-être que c'était sa dernière année, nous ne savions pas que
j'ai essayé de dire qu'ils lui parlaient
parfois et je dis d'accord
patron, ça va peut-être que vous perdez les
classiques mais vous  Je ne peux pas récupérer pour l'
année, alors j'essaie toujours de
reprendre mon fiancé, je suppose que j'ai mis le
plâtre et je suis retourné à l'hôtel pour essayer
de montrer un visage courageux et
le point culminant était que j'allais être à la
maison pour un peu  alors que j'avais un
garçon de cinq ans, j'étais venu
à l'hôtel en costume de poulet et j'ai pensé que c'était
plutôt bien que papa soit à
la maison pendant un petit moment, je me souviens de
m'avoir appelé et d'avoir juste essayé de rester
en contact  cette période parce que j'avais
eu tellement de revers en 2015, je savais
exactement ce qu'il traversait, je savais
à quelle vitesse il pouvait être sur un entraîneur et
quelques autres choses que vous pouvez faire pour
revenir sur votre vélo aussi vite que
possible.  monter dans le train de retour et
voir ce que nous pouvons faire et euh
environ 15 minutes plus tard, j'ai pensé
qu'est-ce que je faisais même ici parce que
j'étais vraiment gêné de
ne pas pouvoir rester loin du vélo
pendant deux jours
avec un bras cassé  que je devais revenir
sur l'entraîneur et j'ai envoyé un texto au mécanicien
j'ai dit tu sais où est mon vélo
euh j'ai dit oh c'est en italie j'ai dit mais
si je veux venir faire une course
la semaine prochaine
non mais tu as un bras cassé  j'ai dit mais
dites que vous m'avez radié vous les gars
c'était seulement quelques semaines avant euh
nous parlons de qui va être
le dernier endroit pour roubaix et c'était
chris jewell jensen ou matt heyman et je
ne pouvais pas croire  ils flottaient même
son nom pour être honnête, il n'avait fait aucune
course, il venait juste d'être sur l'ergo
et j'ai pensé que ce n'était probablement pas une
bonne idée pour le pour lui juste pour
la santé de son bras nous le savions  il
s'entraînait, nous ne savions probablement pas à
quel point il mettait tout en œuvre
pour faire la ligne de départ et
combien cela signifiait pour lui de même prendre la
ligne de départ à perry bay
Je ne me suis pas rendu compte qu'il
était sûr qu'il voulait le faire,
alors j'ai pensé que Crystal Jensen
ira probablement plus loin, mais heyman pourrait
probablement contribuer assez bien pour le
yen au début de cette période compte tenu de son
expérience, nous l'avons donc mis juste
pour
ça.  Je sais qu'Isabela avait parlé à Mattie
menant à la rue Bay
et je
pense que c'était percé à la maison.
pour nous parirubay
2016. ce sera ma 15e tentative de
gagner et ce gars est le premier
je ne sais pas ce qu'il essaie de faire ici
mais je ne pense pas que ça va aider
ils ont dit que ça avait aidé donc je ne sais pas
je  J'essaie
alors quel est le conseil que tu peux donner euh
luca euh ne colle pas tes poignets euh
ce n'est pas si mal
alors euh maddie quel est le euh plan d'
attaque nous n'avons pas de super favori
ici mais nous avons un solide  groupe de
gars qui deviennent en fait assez
expérimentés à cette course et avec le cuckler de jen
en courant six l'année dernière je pense euh je
pense qu'il peut aller encore mieux cette année
donc
nous espérons une bonne journée
certainement l'un de mes jours préférés de l'
année  et
c'est le seul jour de l'année où
j'aimerais vraiment être encore écrivain
le reste de l'année pas tellement mais ça te
manque vraiment aujourd'hui
paris roubaix la reine des classiques
maddie revient vers moi il est comme oh peux
tu prendre ces bras presque jusqu'à la voiture
quand tu reviens je vais
freiner et j'étais comme oh le frein est
déjà parti alors je sais que je  Je vais
freiner
alors d'accord pas de soucis et puis euh l'instant d'après
je
vois maddie sortir du côté du
coup de poing juste frapper avec comme un groupe de
cinq et aller à la pause
maintenant nous entendons que le 16  les coureurs
essaient de forcer la tête ici mais heyman
semble avoir fait partie du groupe
la maison est dans la pause je suis venu à
la radio j'étais comme si je
ne plaisantais pas était-il en train de manger boire
manger boire
[Applaudissements]
nous regardons  maintenant chez les leaders de la
baie de paris deux minutes à 37 secondes c'est
l'écart que nous voyons maintenant peter sagan
et fabian cancellara quelque 40 50 secondes
derrière un groupe contenant le grand
favori tom bonan et maintenant la chasse est
lancée et ça va être un
Entrée intrigante maintenant Paul dans la forêt
se passait dans
la course, vous savez que les radios ne
fonctionnent pas toujours bien et la voiture et c'est le
chaos,
donc je reçois des trucs à la
radio mais vous savez qu'ils ont trois quatre
cinq minutes de retard avec la voiture mais je
savais  que le groupe était divisé et que
quelque chose se passait et je pouvais
les entendre arriver et c'était moins d'une
minute maintenant
[Musique]
et je pensais que je ne voulais pas me faire prendre
sur une section de pavés avec un vent de travers
regardez ce havre mat  ici, il ne fait que
maintenir le rythme et s'éloigner
du reste de l'échappée en ce moment,
sûr qu'il
roule,
c'est un [ __ ] d'idiot pendant des années s'il
attaque ça comme il l'a fait ouais
ils les ont attrapés heyman regarde autour de lui
il évalue il sait que  luke
durbridge est dans ce groupe je suis en quelque sorte arrivé
à maddie j'étais comme maddie c'est une
super situation mec comme ouais cool je
vais attaquer et voici une attaque
au milieu de matthew heyman
brillante balade matt hayman
le grand camp et  la réaction vient
d'ian stanhard
alors matthew le groupe derrière le
groupe cancellara est à 25 secondes 25 secondes
62 kilomètres encore à courir et c'est à
plein régime
quand j'entends quelqu'un la frapper je me rends compte
que c'était que c'était luc alors je suis sur  à
nouveau le mien
mais l'homme qui a maintenant assumé la
responsabilité de la pression sur le
devant de ce groupe est tom bonen en
personne
vernon est sur le front nous avons encore
50k à faire et il déchire ce groupe il
veut décrocher la victoire numéro cinq  à
paris roubaix il a adoré cette course au fil
des ans allez allez allez
[applaudissements]
donc dès qu'il finit l'initié je
panique et j'appuie sur les freins et ça
pourrait être la fin pour heyman il a perdu
la roue matthew heyman et  il a perdu
son élan
il a reculé
c'est ça c'est marubey tout se
résumait à ce que ce
soit le film qui joue
qui va me hanter
je pense que maddie a canalisé
14 ans de colère à ce moment-là
tout le monde l'a écrit
c'est la vie mec
tu as besoin  continuer le combat
continuer
la dernière porte
[Music]
est la bonne
marque
en tant qu'enfant, il aurait eu des affiches de
tom bowden sur son volant, il déchire les
affiches et il arrache le cœur
de tom bowden alors qu'il arrache les
jambes du  reste d'entre eux cette section il
y a beaucoup de sections de gravier heyman
est de retour
quel retour de matthew hayman
il obtient sur la roue de boson hargan
le courage de matthew hayman excellent travail
excellent travail un gars à l'avant
excellent travail
coude il a regardé par-dessus l'épaule
maintenant heyman répond
matt heyman poursuivant tom bowden et
heyman y arrive allez
voici une opportunité en or si vous êtes
matthew hayman maintenant vous devez rester dans
la roue
matthew hayman a remporté deux
courses professionnelles tom bone et 109
les chances sont empilées  contre le
paiement australien pour devenir le deuxième australien
à remporter la course en arrière
cinq pour les sprints
tom bowden
en haut de la piste alors aussi matthew
hayman il prend l'élan il
profite du plongeon potentiel
oh allez allez allez  allez allez
pas d'argent
hayman est en train de sortir il se démarque
autour du refuge extérieur avec son nez
devant
et il essaie de défier mais c'est
matthew heyman c'est un cadeau d'anniversaire précoce
hayman en tient un
[Musique]
oui [
Musique]
[Musique]
est
[  Musique]
c'est un pour les gentils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
conclu
les gars merci beaucoup pour tout
c'est une équipe spéciale et des choses spéciales
se produisent dans une équipe spéciale
[  Musique]
j'avais ma petite fille endormie à côté de moi
et je l'ai réveillée dans les
derniers kilomètres parce que je devais
le partager avec quelqu'un
et euh
et j'ai euh j'étais émotif je le tenais
jusqu'à ce que la bannière shane me sonne
quelques minutes  plus tard et
puis j'ai dû raccrocher je ne pouvais pas je
ne pouvais pas tenir le coup
je suis sorti de la chirurgie vers deux heures du
matin et j'étais sous anesthésie mais j'étais
éveillé et la dame me faisait rouler
dans le couloir  dans ma chambre elle est comme
heyman il gagne la course je suis comme ouais
mat heyman il était dans la course c'est
vrai tu sais non non non
mat heyman
il gagne la course roubaix tu sais et j'étais
comme
mat heyman il il a gagné roubaix tu sais
comme si c'était encore tellement incroyable
qu'il m'a donné l'espoir et peut-être que beaucoup d'
autres espèrent que
cela peut être fait,
je pense que la détermination et le courage à la
fin de la journée vous mèneront bien
plus loin que
le talent le  la plus grande histoire que notre équipe a à partager
est l'évolution de l'endroit où nous avons commencé
et de ce que nous devenons maintenant,
nous avons eu des succès fantastiques, nous avons également eu
des moments vraiment décevants et
dévastateurs
si vous avez une vision et vous entourez
vous-même avec des gens qui croient en
cette vision et ont la même passion que
vous réussirez, la
performance viendra toujours quand le
reste de votre vie sera en ligne et je pense
que c'est euh quelque chose qui nous manque dans
les sports professionnels,
je suppose que ce qui est drôle quand vous regardez
en arrière  c'est comme ça que ça a commencé comme cette
équipe d'adn australienne mais vraiment il a fallu des gens de
différentes cultures de pays différents
et apprendre de ces cultures vraiment
c'est ce qui leur a permis de grandir et
c'est ce qui leur a permis de
réussir
ce que je trouve génial à propos de l'association
avec le bord vert  est que
toute l'équipe s'amuse bien
mais ce n'est pas au détriment des bonnes
manières et de la bonne amitié et cela va jusqu'aux
mécaniciens les
swaniers tout le monde dans l'équipe a
le même esprit et ils se traitent
tous avec un grand respect  donc je pense qu'une
leçon de vie est de respecter
votre prochain et de
profiter pleinement de la vie, vous savez, profitez-en pleinement
parce que vous n'obtenez qu'une seule chance
[Musique]
avant que
nous ne soyons des coureurs,
nous sommes des humains
et cette équipe est vraiment
[Musique]
ombres humaines jouant au plafond
dansant dans la lueur
[Musique]
tout est comme ce soir doit-il
aller
[Musique] il y
a toujours une pluie
qui va tomber sur tout ce qui est doux
et vous avez peur
et l'obscurité est tout  tu vois
mais le soleil brillera
si tu essaies
un peu d'amour
je pense que tu trouveras que
tu peux essayer un petit essai
[Musique]
un peu d'amour
essayez un peu d'amour
pour
essayer le grand
[Musique]
essayez
un peu d'amour
[Musique]
essayez
vous